jacob jonas won nine games last year
just comes off the injured list
really looks sharp in his last outing
when he went four innings and he said
his stamina finally
built up so one on one out to jose abreu
there's a line drive to junis makes the
catch and gets the double play
how about that and that will take care
of all those pitches that moncada used
up on it
now eloy jimenez he was a triple shy
of the cycle last night from a young uh
oh man that was set up for a double play
franco throws
off line good stop by perez and he kept
his foot on the back and they called the
runner out
and jacob junis is telling the umpire
hey that ball glanced off my foot not
the ground so it should have gotten in
there that's a double play
wow june's junas is living right today
i'll say man second time this match has
come back
right to him for a double play in two
innings two double plays that was crazy
albertos wouldn't swing in the bat well
now he hits one off of his
front shin that hurts so he'll take a
little time to
get that feeling back in the foot but
apparently was his back knee
and this is on the fly though oh man he
got he got doubled he got it in his
on his right above his knee oh now alex
gordon
alex gets into one right center field
and deep that's a way back
and alex gordon hits his first home run
of 2020
and the crowd goes wild here at the k
fantastic great swing short
with his swing that's where you let him
generate the power with that
off speed that there was a change up
look like to me up in the zone
and alex just with a good easy
80 swing there you see that even took
his hand off
just met it perfectly got some backspin
and sent that ball for a drink in the
hydration station
that'll bring up nick madrigal still
searching for that elusive
first big league hit well game three for
him he's due
line drive right field save that
baseball
nick madrigal with his first career hit
and it's a
single to right the celebration is on
well it took longer than he would want
it's a ninth at bat
and that's a sigh of relief it's gonna
be a whole lot of hits for nick and
eventually
it's going to surprise you eventually
he's going to hit the ball out of the
ballpark first pitch
from junice is smacked into left center
field that ball is going to get down and
go all the way to the wall
abreu around first he will jog for
second with a lead-off double
well there's a drive for you getting
things going fundamental baseball here
yasmani grandahl right center field up
the alleyway
abreu around third could backstroke home
and the sox have tied the ball game just
like that here in the fourth yashmani
grand all comes through
rbi number five said it a couple of days
ago yasmani is starting to look really
good this is a breaking ball down but he
stayed right with it
and just like that thai ball game zach's
looking for more
nikki lopez comes out of the dugout even
though he has a shin injury
suffered last night alberto modesty
fouled a ball off of his
left quad and then ricocheted off of his
shin
and they're saying it is a quad injury
has come out of the game one one game
here in the fifth inning
two outs now and the full count pitch
is low for ball four and a run comes in
madrigal will cross home plate on the
bases loaded pass to yasmani grand
all and it's now a 2-1 lead for the
white sox in the fifth
2-1 chicago they about hit the royals
six to two
so here's nikki lopez he goes after the
first pitch launches it to left
bronco comes in to score lopez has
himself a double and the royals have
tied it
there you go good placement there royals
answer the white sox run at the top of
the frame with a run of their own
with first and third now one out two two
ball game top seven
and that one back up the middle into
center field to base it here comes
magical to score
and abreu comes through here in the
seventh inning and the white sox have
taken a three to two lead
almost like he took aim to the vacated
middle part of the infield the shortstop
was playing over toward third base some
uh brayu to pull it's a slider up and
jose beat it straight down into the
ground past the pitcher
so nice job by jose abreu first and
second
for yasmani grandahl who had the other
two runs batted in
and the 2-2 is on the ground into center
field of base head robert will turn
third he's on his way toward the plate
he is going to score it is four to two
white sox another run batted in the
third of the game for yasmani grandahl
so holland looking in with the bases
loaded
top of the seventh two outs four two
white sox
nikki to right field that's down for a
base hit
one run is in here comes the second and
the sox make it
six to two hey nikki a two out hit
and the sox by four our lakeside bank
call to the pen
is sparky glenn sparkman this offense we
know isn't going to stop oh and two from
sparkman
on the ground back to the mounds
sparkman loads up a floater over first
base
that was not a bullseye angles coming
around from first and the sox have two
more
a misfire from sparkman and the white
sox now leaded eight to two
well that was not pretty if you're a
royals fan
beautiful if you're a sox fan here is
madrigal owen to the count
and a bouncer right back up the middle
that is going to sneak into center for a
base hit he's got his first run batted
in
here comes mendic to score the ninth
white sox run
so in back to back days a white sox
rookie
has a four hit game why not yesterday of
course it was luis robert today it's
nick madrigal
nine to two here in the seventh 9-2
the sox with the lead bottom of the
ninth inning and a four-hit day for nick
madrigal
first pitch to franco a little nubber
it'll be fielded by madrigal over to
first in time of the white sox have
swept
the kansas city royals madrigal finishes
off the game
and he completes his best game as a
major leaguer four hits
for nick madrigal and a 9-2 sox victory
to sweep the kansas city royals and that
feels
real good four in a row stoney